i don't know i don't look at you as
someone who gets intimidated but
was there a time in your life where
you know working with these big actors
having to step up having to prove
yourself did you get nervous did you get
anxiety did you get intimidated by
anybody
i got to be honest with you and i i
really mean this uh
you know you talk about
people have asked me over the time and
i'm a character guy i you know i
play specific things in movies i try to
fully realize that piece of the puzzle
but when you work with with
the movie stars that i've worked with
over time
they're really good actors
and
that's all they want to do
and there's a reason why they're making
movie stars is because they're really
good actors right most of them um
you know so
i i don't i don't i can't honestly
remember that i ever felt like really
overwhelmed in that sort of a thing
back it up for a second not too so i
moved to new york when i'm 21 when i
started the american academy of dramatic
arts and as i said all i really want to
do
sure i want to learn theater i want to
work in television and i did and that
but i want to i want to work in film
i was 36 when i got my first job on a
film 36 36 years old i'm 15 years
wondering is it ever going to come my
way so by the time it came around in two
years and as the world turns being in
front of that camera four days out of
the week you know i could have swore the
first six months i was on as the world
turn that the boom was picking up my
heartbeat
you know because you're nervous oh it's
just terrified
uh you know trying to be smooth and just
like horrible but after two years of
playing
josh the misunderstood farmhand you know
i mean i really like settled down